yesterday after a lot of outrage Walmart  was forced to stop selling a holiday  sweater that appeared to show Santa do a  cocaine with the caption let it snow  Walmart Walmart was smelling that  sweater people freaked out that had to  poet yeah where woman that butter was  like I don't I didn't know what it was  exactly yeah and then that it turns out  Walmart had to pull other sweaters as  well they had to stop selling this one  that showed Santa in a meth lab it says  Merry Christmas  yeah they had to get rid of this one  this one showing Santa with crack  cocaine it says jingle bell rocks  there's this one showing Santa strung  out on heroin with the caption do you  see what I see and finally one with  Santa and mrs. Claus called merry triple  Xmas  [Applause]